all right what holds you back
now this is the guiding question for
deutsche chevelle's new multimedia based
project life links the website addresses
young people all over the world on
dot t e slash lifelinks they can use
social streams to see what's going on in
the social media lifelinks is about
personal stories told intimately by
young reporters like yalda zarbaksh
and for the first episode yada went to
south korea i met a young woman there
who made it out of north korea
a half hour's drive north of seoul i get
my first glimpse of the electrified
fence
like most of the north korean defectors
cayenne escaped through china since
crossing the border that separates the
two koreas is nearly impossible
it feels weird standing here looking
down on the most isolated country in the
world i wonder how it is for kaiyan
seeing her home country across that
river
i wish i could see my parents standing
there
there's no way for me to tell them i'm
alive
i left over three years ago they
probably think i'm dead
every year around two to three thousand
north koreans defect to the south in the
last two years that number has gone down
according to south korean authorities
that is due to stricter controls on
north korea's border to china
during my visit to korea everyone was
preparing for chisok a national holiday
where koreans traveled to their
ancestral villages and gather with their
families
one essential part is the traditional
dress the woman wear the hanbok
how would your mother react if she would
see you like this um
i think my mother would feel sorry that
she could never buy this for me
i think she'd be sad
while others prepared the traditional
feast cayenne prayed for her mother not
to starve
so that one day they can meet again
live links premieres on deutsche bay on
saturday at 2 30 utc must watch